think a lot of people are staying in
jobs for one or two years after they
realize the job sucks or is not for them
two or three weeks in and I think the
reason they're doing that is they're
worried that it's going to look bad on
their resume and I just don't think
that's as real as people think in
today's environment I just don't know
what else to say to me the way I look at
it is number one if a company looks at
your resume when you submit it and sees
that you only work somewhere for two
months and that eliminates you you
probably don't want to work for that
company number two if you get in the
door you can just explain that you used
your self-awareness to recognize it
wasn't a good fit or you undercovered
this or that or the other thing or you
sold a bag of goods that weren't real
and just the thought of people in their
20s wasting two years because they want
their resume to not look awkward to then
get another job at a place that would
judge you on that resume it just feels
like one big [__] Circle so
recommendation of the day don't
overthink it like if the job sucks
bounce it's not gonna really [__] up
your resume in the world that we're
actually living